[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues mesdames et messieurs les
ministres monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale le 13 juillet
dernier je vous interrogé en commission
de la culture sur mes vive inquiétude
concernant votre ministère les
situations de l'école en France après
votre nomination je vous demandais de
nous rassurer trois mois plus tard mes
inquiétudes demeurent le président de la
République a décidé lui-même de lancer
l'année scolaire en réunissant les
acteurs et les réacteurs d'académie
pensez-vous que les lampes pour
transformer l'école doit être si
puissants qui ne puisse venir que du
chef de l'État cette verticalité
interroge sur votre rôle et vos marges
de manœuvre tout en posant de nouveau la
question rupture ou continuité après
votre prédécesseur monsieur le ministre
les téléréalités vous rattrapent la
rentrée scolaire n'a pas été à la
hauteur il n'y avait pas d'enseignant
devant chaque classe et donc a été même
formé en quatre jours les difficultés de
terrain se multiplient des enchantements
général des enseignants et aux et
signalements pour atteinte à la laïcité
votre communication prudente elle a
encore insuffisante
la communauté éducative a besoin de
directives clair d'être soutenu d'une
volonté politique ferme ou récent propos
à l'étranger vont également inquiété
vous avez monsieur le ministre pensez
pouvoir affirmer à New York du site qui
est des traces d'anti-américanisme dans
les discours politique français vous
avez suggéré la possibilité d'évoquer
avec nuance les inégalités raciales de
notre pays non monsieur le ministre la
France n'est pas raciste nous sommes
nous aussi aux questions sensibles aux
questions d'inégalité n'abîmez pas les
trois Génos principes fondateurs cessez
de vous positionner comme universitaire
militante ne tendez pas de nous imposer
à walkisme de salon chair à notre
président retaillaux incompatible avec
vos responsabilités politiques soyez
ministres et enfin la seule question qui
s'impose monsieur le ministre quel est
votre vision de l'école où voulez vous
emmener les enseignants et nos enfants